okay we have some interesting
discussions that our audience is
engaging in on the David Pakman show
subreddit which you can find at david
pakman.com slash our IDI di t the first
one brought up by one of the more than
eight thousand viewers and listeners
regularly participating they ask in
relation to my clip earlier this week
about alexandria casio Cortez's seventy
percent marginal tax rate proposal or
idea will a steep progressive tax system
encourage the wealthy to leave the
country david or anyone who's willing to
share opinions i've recently read that
france is struggling with protesters
since McCrone is unwilling to raise
taxes on the wealthy last time they
tried tax revenue went down due to these
wealthy taxpayers simply leaving the
country i morally and economically
except the basis of a progressive tax
system but do we underestimate the
potential of the same thing happening in
the United States we had a progressive
system in the 60s but it must have been
much harder to move to a different
country then well we still have a
progressive system is is 0.1 it's just
not as steeply progressive at the top
end so there's I've heard this brought
up a couple of times there's a few
things to consider number one based on
the law just moving to another country
out of the United States does not
eliminate your tax responsibilities to
the United States you can get out of
paying taxes to the US if you not only
move out but relinquish your citizenship
in order to do that you unless you want
to have no citizenship which I don't
know if that even really works
you need to have citizenship elsewhere
so simply saying I'm out and I don't
have to pay taxes to the US anymore it's
actually much more difficult to do the
other thing is that taxes if you want to
go somewhere with significantly lower
taxes such that it would justify
uprooting and leaving the country in
which you live there aren't that many
places most Americans would enjoy living
that have significantly lower taxes yes
there are places where if a more
progressive tax system was put in place
here Western developed countries with
slightly lower top marginal tax rates
there's no question about that but at a
certain point it would become a
you know can you actually stop paying
the American taxes if you leave if you
never plan to come back you can just not
pay them just don't come back to the US
ever I don't think most Americans who
would be leaving for tax reasons plan to
never come back at all and then it's
also how much do you save versus the
trouble of uprooting and moving so would
some people move out of the US with a
high top marginal tax rate yes they
would would their tax liability to the
u.s. go to zero not for most of them and
would it really be worth it to them to
uproot and abandon their country you'd
have to ask them but the number of
people who would actually do it I don't
think is as big as this poster is
suggesting also from the david pakman
show subreddit this again a poster
asking who will be the first to accuse
david pakman of sexual misconduct a
hashtag me to poll this has come up in
hatred mail before and the options are
that someone that I went to school with
is gonna accuse me of sexual misconduct
someone who I taught I guess at Boston
College someone who worked on the show
someone who works in the same industry
like someone else I guess from from
progressive media someone I went on a
date with or a fan I can assure you that
there is not going to be any credible
allegation of sexual assault against me
in fact there was an attempt I haven't
spoken too much about this but there was
I don't even know if you knew about this
Pat I think I mentioned it there was a
movement that tried to start floating
fake sexual assault allegations against
me and they were very briefly
investigated by the journalists who were
contacted obviously and immediately
found not to be credible and then it
just kind of evaporated into thin air so
do I doubt that at some point someone
will try to prove some kind of point
against me by making those allegations
true I don't doubt that I think that
that's already happened and that could
happen again but for people waiting for
my downfall because of a me-too movement
moment I would not hold my breath if I
were you yeah in the wake of the meets
who scandal meat soup movement there
were so many right-wingers who are
saying that just about every man is that
risk and anyone can accuse anyone of
sexual assault and it's going to be
viewed as credible and believed
this kind of shows otherwise it's not so
hard to make up a fake sexual assault
allegation and get away with it
it is hard in fact is what you actually
is difficult to to make that up yeah
david pakman.com slash our IDI di t
joined the discussion respectful
political discussion